Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
你好，我是 Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先向大家预告一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师 Lisa Johnson 发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。挑战中还有由 Lisa 本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent 博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是 Marianne Trent 博士。
It is an absolute pleasure to have you here. And thank you as ever for listening or watching, as you may be watching this on YouTube. Today's episode came about from a conversation with a LinkedIn connection, because I love networking with people. And we were talking about improving access in psychology, and that's where the idea for this podcast episode came about today. I am joined by a lovely man called Cull, who is going to be talking us through leadership, change, inclusion, all of those good things. Hope you will find it so useful and I will look forward to catching you on the other
非常高兴你能来到这里。一如既往，感谢你的收听或观看（如果你是在 YouTube 上观看的话）。今天这期节目的灵感来源于我与一位 LinkedIn 好友的对话，因为我喜欢与人建立联系。我们当时在讨论如何改善心理学领域的准入问题，这期播客的创意便由此而来。今天我邀请到了一位可爱的男士 Cull，他将为我们讲解领导力、变革、包容性以及所有这些积极的内容。希望你会觉得非常受用，我期待在节目的另一端与你相见。
side. Hi, welcome along to today's episode of the podcast. I am joined today by my lovely guest, Carl Mahe. Carl, thank you for joining us. No, thank you for having me. It's an absolute pleasure. Lovely. So could you tell the audience a little bit about you and your background, if that's okay yes absolutely so I spent 32 years in the police service from the age of 16 yes I was a 16 spotty face kid when I joined the police there was back in January 1983 it's all I ever wanted to do from the age of 10 it was like my dream and back in those days you used to have full-time police cadets and I applied to 26 police forces and I just committed to whichever one would say yes to me first I just joined then
你好，欢迎收听今天的播客。今天我的嘉宾是可爱的 Carl Mahe。Carl，谢谢你参加我们的节目。不，谢谢你的邀请。这是我的荣幸。太好了。如果可以的话，能请你向听众介绍一下你自己和你的背景吗？好的，没问题。我从 16 岁起就在警队工作了 32 年。是的，我 1983 年 1 月加入警队时还是个满脸青春痘的 16 岁孩子。从 10 岁起，这就是我唯一想做的事，是我的梦想。在那个年代，会有全职的警校学员制度，我向 26 个警队投了申请，我决定无论哪一个先录取我，我就加入哪一个。
it happened to be in Derbyshire so I up sticks from my concrete jungle in Wolverhampton and landed in the beautiful green fields of Derbyshire and been here ever since. Amazing oh I feel like there's lots and lots of questions I can ask you about mental health in policing and mental health in the people you look after in policing but that's probably a separate issue. So how did you get from being working in the police field to where you are now? Well my journey in the police service was quite an interesting one given that the kind of job that we were doing, but also my own personal journey. When I joined the police service, I was literally a brown speck in a sea of white. Two thirds of my service was spent at leadership levels.
结果是德比郡警队，所以我收拾行囊，离开了伍尔弗汉普顿的“水泥森林”，来到了德比郡美丽的绿地，并一直待在那里。太棒了。我觉得关于警务工作中的心理健康，以及你们在警务工作中照顾的人群的心理健康，我有很多很多问题想问你，但这可能是一个单独的话题。那么，你是如何从警务领域转行到现在的呢？嗯，考虑到我们所做的工作性质，以及我个人的经历，我在警队的旅程相当有趣。当我加入警队时，我简直是白人海洋中的一点棕色。我三分之二的职业生涯是在领导层度过的。
Towards the end, my last third in the police service in my last eight, nine years, I was what they call a gold commander, sitting at superintendent, chief superintendent level, or a gold commander for all major incidents, critical incidents. I was the person, I guess, where all the problems would be sitting on my shoulders. If something went wrong, I'd be responsible for that. So I've been responsible for major public disorder issues, firearms incidents, bomb hoaxes, bomb threats, major football matches and things of that nature, as well as managing my day-to-day department of, you know, up to 400 people at a time. And what I learned in the police service was this how powerful good leadership can be and how it can impact and empower people but also how it can destroy people's lives uh one of the first things i used to say to any leadership team that i would take over in a new department is that we need to be mindful of the language that comes out of our mouths because it can either empower people, inspire people,
在职业生涯的最后三分之一，也就是最后八九年里，我担任所谓的“黄金指挥官”（Gold Commander），处于警司或总警司级别，负责所有重大事件和突发事件。我想，我就是那个所有问题都压在肩上的人。如果出了什么差错，我得负责。所以我负责过重大的公共秩序问题、枪支事件、炸弹恶作剧、炸弹威胁、大型足球比赛等，同时还要管理我日常部门中多达 400 人的团队。我在警队学到的是：良好的领导力是多么强大，它如何影响和赋能他人，但也如何摧毁人们的生活。我接手新部门时，对领导团队说的第一件事就是：我们需要注意我们口中说出的话，因为它们要么能赋能、激励人们，
and help people move forward, or it can destroy people's lives, and they will take it away home with them, and they'll infect their families and their friends with how we treat them. So I realized for me that people in leadership, the concept of people is very, very important. And when I left the police service I wanted to help other organizations create those kind of cultures and those conversations
帮助人们前进，要么会摧毁人们的生活。他们会把这些话带回家，并用我们对待他们的方式去影响他们的家人和朋友。所以我意识到，对于领导者来说，人的概念非常非常重要。当我离开警队时，我想帮助其他组织创造那种文化和对话，
where there was trust throughout the organization greater performance in the organization as a result the people became much more emotionally intelligent and and and stop using that as a glib phrase to truly understand what emotional intelligence in practice looks like and now i have the great honor pleasure of teaching other people exactly that i work with leaders on a one-to-one coaching basis i design programs for universities for organizations and i help organizations change their culture and I'm sort of in my sweet spot I guess. It found you you know you just you ended up where you needed to be. Tell us a little bit about how you've been working alongside doctoral programs lately Carl. Well I mean this came sort of out
在组织内部建立信任，从而提高绩效。结果，人们变得更加具有情商，并且不再仅仅把这当作一句空话，而是真正理解情商在实践中是什么样子。现在，我有幸教导他人这些内容。我以一对一辅导的方式与领导者合作，为大学和组织设计课程，帮助组织改变文化。我想，我正处于自己的最佳状态。这就像是命中注定，你最终找到了自己的归宿。能跟我们聊聊你最近是如何与博士项目合作的吗，Carl？嗯，这对我来说有点出乎意料，
of the blue for me really and I'll have to admit to some imposter syndrome kicking in for me because essentially I was being asked to teach psychology to psychologists. And there was this internal conversation inside myself as to whether I could actually do that. But the way it happened was this. I'd been working for a number of universities who had asked me to come in to design programs for them and then deliver those programs to help those underrepresented groups of members of I designed a program which was a very pragmatic program based upon the 26 competency areas that we talk about in social emotional intelligence. As a member of the Institute of Social Emotional Intelligence over in America, I drilled down deep into these 26 competency areas and pulled out some pragmatic tools, if you like, and techniques, leadership techniques that I could teach people.
我必须承认，我当时产生了一些“冒名顶替综合征”，因为本质上，我被要求向心理学家教授心理学。我内心一直在纠结自己是否真的能做到。但事情是这样的：我曾为一些大学工作，他们邀请我为他们设计课程，并向那些代表性不足的群体传授这些课程。我设计了一个非常务实的课程，基于我们在社会情感智能中讨论的 26 个能力领域。作为美国社会情感智能研究所的成员，我深入研究了这 26 个能力领域，并提取了一些务实的工具和领导力技巧，我可以教给人们。
And for me, any program that I design has to have some pragmatism involved within there. People need to be able to grab hold of something and then be able to apply that in their lives. So we brought this program together for the underrepresented groups in this university and we saw some incredible success as a result of it. It was a six-module program spread over about three months and we saw people being promoted and applying for much more senior positions and that the university itself was seeing this representation this diverse
对我来说，我设计的任何课程都必须包含务实性。人们需要能够掌握一些东西，然后将其应用到生活中。所以我们为这所大学的代表性不足群体整合了这个课程，并取得了令人难以置信的成功。这是一个为期三个月、包含六个模块的课程，我们看到人们获得了晋升，申请了更高级别的职位，而大学本身也看到了他们所渴望的那种多元化的代表性。
representation that they had aspired to so a few months later I got approached by the Trent doctoral program which I think was a collaboration with the schools of psychology from Lincoln and from University of Nottingham and they have they, look, we've got some underrepresentation as well, so could you run a programme, the same programme, for our postgraduates to help them to aspire towards the doctoral programme? So we ran the same programme with two cohorts of assistant psychologists, and what we saw at the end of it all was I think we had four or five people who were successful in applying for the doctoral program and those
几个月后，Trent 博士项目找到了我，我想这是林肯大学和诺丁汉大学心理学院的合作项目。他们说：“看，我们也有一些代表性不足的情况，你能为我们的研究生开设同样的课程，帮助他们向博士项目迈进吗？”所以我们为两批助理心理学家开设了同样的课程。在课程结束时，我想我们有四五个人成功申请到了博士项目，而那些
that weren't successful or those that chose not to apply actually went on to see some level of success in the work that they were doing so So we had a number of people being promoted, and we had one in particular who reached out to me and said, hey, I went for a job interview at a much more senior level, and I used all the techniques that we'd learnt on the programme, but I got told I was unsuccessful. But the reason I was unsuccessful was apparently because I was too good and instead I was offered the job of the manager for the post that I'd applied for so she went off
没有成功或选择不申请的人，实际上在他们所做的工作中也取得了一定程度的成功。我们有几个人获得了晋升，其中有一个人特别联系我，说：“嘿，我去应聘了一个更高级别的职位，我用了我们在课程中学到的所有技巧，但我被告知失败了。但失败的原因竟然是因为我太优秀了，相反，他们直接给了我那个职位的经理职位。”所以她
and got a bit of a bonus job I guess. That's a great result we must have felt absolutely thrilled with that and I guess my own experience with the um the aspiring psychologist membership is that just it's incredible when you get to follow stories and when you see your work make a real difference to real people's lives it's really really um it's just you know the sort of thing and I guess you'll have those memories from the police as well you know and throughout your career when you feel like you've been able to make a difference it's just a golden nugget that you get to keep forever and it's really lovely. Oh, there's no substitute for that. And stories are the things that keep memories alive for us.
算是获得了一份意外之喜。那真是个伟大的结果，你一定为此感到非常激动。我想我自己在“有抱负的心理学家”会员项目中的经验是，当你能追踪这些故事，看到你的工作对真实的人的生活产生真正的影响时，那种感觉真是不可思议。这就像是……我想你在警队时也会有这样的记忆，在你的职业生涯中，当你觉得能够有所作为时，那是一颗永远珍藏的“金块”，真的很美好。哦，没有什么能替代那种感觉。故事是让我们记忆鲜活的东西。
You know, when we put a memory in the context of a story for me, I think it brings it alive. So in much of the programmes that I deliver, stories sit at the very, very heart. And one of the modules on the programme that I delivered was based around public speaking. I mean, I teach public speaking. So on this particular module, all of the candidates,
你知道，当我们把记忆置于故事的语境中时，我认为它就变得鲜活了。所以在我教授的许多课程中，故事都处于核心地位。我教授的课程中有一个模块是关于公开演讲的。我的意思是，我教授公开演讲。所以在这个特定的模块中，所有的候选人，
all the delegates had a very intense day of learning how to do public speaking. And one of the elements was how do you structure a story and for me a story has to have a beginning a middle and an end the beginning is really setting the scene and talking about the adversary the the act two if you like part two of the story is really about the journey that you undertake the you know the ups and downs if you think of the hobbit and all of the things is really about the journey that you undertake the you know the ups and downs if you think of the hobbit and all of the things that the hobbit had to do uh in in in the lord of the rings and then finally it's that realization and implementing this newfound knowledge and wisdom and then what happened as a result of that so those are the three acts for storytelling and
所有的学员都经历了一整天高强度的公开演讲学习。其中一个要素是如何构建故事。对我来说，一个故事必须有开头、中间和结尾。开头是真正地铺陈场景并谈论对手；第二幕，也就是故事的第二部分，是关于你所经历的旅程，那些起起落落。如果你想想《霍比特人》以及霍比特人在《指环王》中必须做的一切，那就是关于你所经历的旅程，那些起起落落；最后，是那种领悟，将新发现的知识和智慧付诸实践，以及随之而来的结果。这就是讲故事的三幕剧。
i think storytelling is critical to any learning that we ever undertake in our lives. I love that. I love that. And as you're talking, I was just thinking, maybe Carl can get me to stop saying um. Here's the thing, Marion. I still say um and um. And I purposely now do it. And the reason I just did it there and the reason why I do it is because it's real you know when we're having a conversation we um and ah we
我认为讲故事对于我们一生中进行的任何学习都至关重要。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。当你说话时，我一直在想，也许 Carl 能帮我改掉说“嗯”的习惯。事情是这样的，Marianne。我依然会说“嗯”和“啊”。我现在是有意为之。我刚才那样做，以及我之所以这样做，是因为这很真实。你知道，当我们进行对话时，我们会“嗯”和“啊”，
don't think twice of it so why should we think about it when we're in front of a camera or on a stage I have delivered I would say in the region of 200 keynote presentations in the last two years of lockdown. And I guess I will have ummed and ahed in every single one. You know, I've done television interviews. I've spoken on stages. At one point, I think I spoke to 1,000 people. And I um and ah, because I think it's natural. And people are drawn.
我们不会多想。那么为什么当我们在镜头前或舞台上时，我们要去在意它呢？在封锁期间的过去两年里，我大概做了 200 场主题演讲。我想我在每一场演讲中都会有“嗯”和“啊”。你知道，我做过电视采访，在舞台上发过言。有一次，我想我对着 1000 人演讲。我还是会“嗯”和“啊”，因为我认为这是自然的。人们会被吸引。
People are drawn to people who come across as being really natural and authentic. And I think that's the new superpower in this changing world in which we exist that people are looking for. People are drawn to authenticity. So why be that absolutely polished individual when you can be real? I love that. We're embracing my ums when I listen I think it's the trauma episode of this podcast I was obviously wanting to make sure I handled it really sensitively so it's really slowing it down and honestly I feel like I need
人们会被那些表现得非常自然和真实的人所吸引。我认为这是我们所处的这个不断变化的世界中，人们正在寻找的一种新的“超能力”。人们被真实性所吸引。所以，当你能做真实的人时，为什么要成为那个完美无瑕的个体呢？我喜欢这个。我在听的时候会拥抱我的“嗯”。我想这是这期播客的创伤主题，我显然想确保我处理得非常敏感，所以语速真的很慢。老实说，我觉得我需要
to do an like an um bop like bingo where people listen to it count the ums and then there's a prize for whoever gets the right number because there are are lots of ums. But it is a great episode as well. So I will embrace the ums. Thank you. I mean, one way of reducing the number of ums, I mean, I would always say don't eliminate them. That's my personal take on it. But you can reduce them just simply by slowing down. So the reason why we um and ah is to give ourselves thinking time and space, right? So rather than um and ah, just pause. Just pause and allow yourself time to think. And actually, when it comes out in the final recording, it doesn't sound anywhere near as bad as you think it is in the moment of taking that pause. So we're so scared of pausing.
做一个“嗯”的宾果游戏，让人们听的时候数一数“嗯”的次数，然后给猜对的人发奖品，因为确实有很多“嗯”。但这期节目也很棒。所以我接受这些“嗯”。谢谢。我的意思是，减少“嗯”次数的一种方法是——我总是说不要完全消除它们，这是我的个人看法。但你可以通过放慢语速来减少它们。我们“嗯”和“啊”的原因是为了给自己留出思考的时间和空间，对吧？所以与其“嗯”和“啊”，不如停顿一下。停顿一下，给自己思考的时间。实际上，当它出现在最终录音中时，听起来并不像你在停顿的那一刻感觉到的那么糟糕。我们太害怕停顿了。
We want to fill every single gap with some kind of noise. But actually, when you take that pause and you listen back, you think, wow, that sounds pretty good. So all the best interviews, all the best presenters in the world know how to take a pause. Good. I will bear that in mind. I don't notice my ums at the time that I do them I think it is anyone I'm editing back you know you're editing the podcast
我们想用某种噪音填补每一个空白。但实际上，当你停顿一下再回听时，你会觉得，哇，听起来还不错。所以世界上所有最好的采访者、最好的演讲者都知道如何停顿。好的。我会记住这一点。我在说话时并没有注意到自己的“嗯”，我想每个人都是这样。当你回听剪辑时，
you're like oh there's a lot of ums there but yeah I'm going to embrace them and I'm also gonna yeah just think more mindfully about that um I know that my audience will have listened to you saying you know there's these key concepts in emotional intelligence. I don't expect you to go through them all, but could you give us like a flavour of a couple of your favourites of the key components of these? Oh, absolutely. I think these will resonate with a lot of people.
你会觉得“哦，那里有很多‘嗯’”，但没关系，我会拥抱它们，我也会更用心地思考那个“嗯”。我知道我的听众听过你说“情商中有这些关键概念”。我不指望你把它们全部讲一遍，但你能给我们介绍几个你最喜欢的关键组成部分吗？哦，当然。我认为这些会引起很多人的共鸣。
So let's think about emotional intelligence as almost like a mountain. So you have the bit that you can see and then the bit that goes underneath that you really didn't know was there or you didn't know how it's made up so the bit that most people know about when it comes to emotional intelligence are is that it's made up of four quadrants okay now each one of these quadrants is critically important in any leadership journey. So those four quadrants are self-awareness. Any leader worth their salt should have the ability, the constant ability to reflect, inwardly reflect, and as a consequence of that, be able to move on to the second quadrant, which is self-management. Now, let me throw some
让我们把情商想象成一座山。你有你能看到的部分，还有隐藏在下面、你不知道它是由什么构成的部分。大多数人所了解的情商，是由四个象限组成的。好的，这四个象限中的每一个在任何领导力旅程中都至关重要。这四个象限是：自我意识。任何称职的领导者都应该具备这种能力，即持续的反思能力，并因此能够进入第二个象限，即自我管理。现在，让我举一些
examples in here so it makes sense. So for example, despite the fact that I did 32 years in police service, I've got nearly three decades worth of leadership experience behind me, I am still constantly curious and I'm still growing. So I recently was honoured to have been invited into a very, very select society of leaders. It's called the Society of Leadership Fellows in Windsor Castle. There's only 250 fellows in the whole world. So for me to have been chosen, I was like, wow, you know, where did this come from? So I had my first opportunity to go to a physical meeting,
例子，这样更容易理解。例如，尽管我在警队工作了 32 年，拥有近三十年的领导经验，但我仍然保持好奇心，并且仍在成长。最近，我有幸受邀加入了一个非常非常精选的领导者协会，叫温莎城堡的“领导力研究员协会”（Society of Leadership Fellows）。全世界只有 250 名研究员。所以对我来说，能被选中，我当时想：“哇，这是从哪儿来的？”所以我有了第一次去参加线下会议的机会，
and it was just a few days ago. I think it was last Friday. And it was a beautiful summer's day, and I drove to Windsor Castle, and I drove over there. I got a security pass so I could walk into those areas that other people couldn't walk into. And I just found myself, as I'm looking over this balustrade, and I'm looking across the field, and I could see Eton,
就在几天前。我想是上周五。那是一个美丽的夏日，我开车去了温莎城堡。我拿到了安全通行证，这样我就可以走进其他人无法进入的区域。我发现自己站在栏杆旁，眺望着田野，可以看到远处的伊顿公学，
Eton College in the distance. I'm thinking, wow, where have I landed? But the whole day was incredibly deep for me because they took us, they helped us to, the concept of the day was crafting your story as a leader. And the idea was to explore where you've been in terms of your learning, your understanding, your values, your visions, and to follow that story through to where you are right now. So at the conclusion of the day, it was, where are you right now? And we were asked to write down about
我心想：“哇，我这是到了哪里？”但这一整天对我来说都非常深刻，因为他们引导我们，帮助我们——那一天的概念是“打造你作为领导者的故事”。其理念是探索你在学习、理解、价值观、愿景方面的历程，并将这个故事延续到你现在的状态。所以在一天结束时，问题是：“你现在在哪里？”我们被要求写下大约
three or four paragraphs describing where we were right now. Now, I've got that written down here in front of me. I found myself just sitting down and I just wrote. I had it done in five minutes. I just wrote about three or four paragraphs in a language that I wouldn't ordinarily have used. But I remember one phrase that I used. I said, I find myself looking at myself as if I were in a glass box, such as similar to the one in Crystal Maze, where there is air being pumped into this box
三四段描述我们目前状态的文字。现在，我手头就有写好的东西。我发现自己坐下来就开始写。我五分钟就写完了。我用了一种我平时不会用的语言写了三四段。但我记得我用过的一个短语。我说：“我发现自己看着自己，就像在玻璃盒子里一样，类似于《水晶迷宫》（Crystal Maze）里的那个，空气被泵入这个盒子里，
and there's ticker tape literally all around me. And on every piece of ticker tape is the word opportunity. Those that I grab, I own. Those that I don't, I don't worry about because there is so much opportunity in my hand right now that I can actually do anything that I want with it. And it's true to where I am right now. Just lately, in the last year, I have been involved in all sorts
周围全是纸带。每一张纸带上都写着‘机会’这个词。我抓住的那些，我就拥有了。那些我没抓住的，我也不担心，因为我现在手中就有如此多的机会，我实际上可以用它们做任何我想做的事。”这确实是我现在的状态。就在最近一年，我参与了各种各样的
of leadership development programmes. I've carried out cultural diagnostic audits of organisations. I co-created a police drama that's being filmed as we speak right now by the BBC in Scotland. I mean, I never thought that would happen. And I've learned the philosophy for me in life is just to say yes to everything. And when I say yes to everything, all the things that excite me will come my way. And some will drop off the edge, but a lot of them will stick and we'll just go forward. And it's created this abundant life. So leadership awareness, self-awareness is critically important. Self-management is really
领导力发展项目。我执行过组织的文化诊断审计。我共同创作了一部警察剧，目前正在苏格兰由 BBC 拍摄。我的意思是，我从没想过会发生这种事。我学到的生活哲学就是对一切说“是”。当我对比一切说“是”时，所有让我兴奋的事情都会来到我身边。有些会掉队，但很多会留下来，我们会继续前进。它创造了这种丰盛的生活。所以领导力意识、自我意识至关重要。自我管理实际上是
about understanding, okay, so what are the habits? What are the things that don't serve me? And what am I going to do about them? So this is really hard. This is stuff that you have to give up where you're creating new habits. So when I wrote my book, Smash the Habit, it was really about physical habits. You know, 20 years ago, I was a big smoker, big drinker, big meat eater. I was the guy, if I went into a restaurant, I had to have the biggest steak on the menu. And overnight, I stopped drinking, smoking, eating meat, fish, eggs, and I have never turned back. Seven years ago, I gave up drinking fizzy pop, sugary drinks, tea and coffee overnight, and I've never gone back. Six years ago, I gave up drinking milk.
关于理解：好的，那么有哪些习惯？哪些事情对我没有帮助？我该怎么处理它们？这真的很难。这是你必须放弃一些东西来创造新习惯的过程。所以当我写《粉碎习惯》（Smash the Habit）这本书时，它实际上是关于身体习惯的。你知道，20 年前，我是一个大烟民、大酒鬼、大肉食者。我就是那种走进餐厅必须点菜单上最大牛排的人。但一夜之间，我停止了喝酒、抽烟、吃肉、鱼、蛋，我再也没有回头。七年前，我一夜之间戒掉了碳酸饮料、含糖饮料、茶和咖啡，我再也没有回头。六年前，我戒掉了牛奶。
You must have had some withdrawal headaches, I'm thinking, from all of that. Do you know what? I genuinely cannot remember if I had it. I must have had something. But my passion was so strong that I would have just ridden over it. And this is to say that I'm not unique. It's just that the clarity of thought was so powerful for me that I was much more committed. And that's what quadrant two of emotional intelligence is all about. Quadrant three is saying, okay, now that I i've fixed myself now let's look outside of myself so quadrant three is all about social awareness really understanding how the world works around you so if you're in an organization for example
我想你一定经历过戒断性头痛吧。你知道吗？我真的不记得我是否有过。我肯定经历过什么。但我的热情如此强烈，以至于我可以直接克服它。这并不是说我是独一无二的。只是思维的清晰度对我来说太强大了，所以我更加坚定。这就是情商第二象限的全部内容。第三象限是说：好的，既然我已经修复了自己，现在让我们看看自身之外。所以第三象限完全是关于社会意识，真正理解你周围的世界是如何运作的。例如，如果你在一个组织中，
or let's assume that you're going for a doctoral program this is one of the things i taught the the the the delegates that came onto the program, I said, what are the expectations, do you think, of you being on a doctoral program? What are the hoops that you have to jump through? What policies are there? What givens are there that you have to achieve? And how many of you have ever tried that and still failed? And a lot of them put their hands up and said, okay,
或者假设你要去参加博士项目，这是我教给参加课程的学员的事情之一。我说：“你认为博士项目对你有什么期望？你必须跳过哪些障碍？有哪些政策？有哪些你必须达到的既定目标？你们中有多少人尝试过这些却依然失败了？”他们很多人举手说：“好的，
so what else is there? What is underneath the surface? What are the nuances? What is the language that goes on? What are the groups that you can go and visit, that you can align yourself with? What relationships can you develop? What conversations can you have that actually increases your level of knowledge,
那么还有什么呢？表面之下是什么？有哪些细微差别？有哪些正在进行的对话？有哪些你可以去访问、可以与之结盟的群体？你可以发展什么关系？你可以进行什么样的对话来真正提高你的知识水平，
your overall level of knowledge? And it's the same in organizations. A lot of people get frustrated in organizations and say, oh, I don't fit here, you know, and I will never get promoted. And the reason why they get frustrated is because they don't understand the nuances of the organization. And this is not about nepotism, it's just the nuances, because wherever there are human beings, you will always find these subconscious unconscious biases that exist because it's a natural facet of being a human being so start understanding that kind of stuff and finally and probably the most important and probably the most powerful if you
你的整体知识水平？”在组织中也是如此。很多人在组织中感到沮丧，说：“哦，我不适合这里，我永远不会得到晋升。”他们感到沮丧的原因是他们不了解组织的细微差别。这与裙带关系无关，这只是细微差别，因为只要有人类的地方，你总会发现这些潜意识的偏见存在，因为这是人类天生的一部分。所以开始理解这些东西。最后，可能是最重要、如果你
get it right is relationship building who do you reach out to to build one-on-one relationships deep lasting relationships. I'm an introvert by nature despite the fact that I can stand on a stage to speak to a thousand people. My introversion is such that I prefer one-on-one conversations but when I meet people I develop strong deep lasting relationships and that's who I am. But when you do that then you'll find that people will elevate you as you elevate other people. People will recommend you as you recommend other people. Your relationships become much, much
做对了可能最强大的，就是建立关系。你联系谁来建立一对一的关系？深厚、持久的关系。我天生内向，尽管我可以站在舞台上对一千人演讲。我的内向在于我更喜欢一对一的对话，但当我遇到人时，我会发展出深厚、持久的关系，这就是我。但当你这样做时，你会发现当你提升他人时，人们也会提升你。当你推荐他人时，人们也会推荐你。你的关系质量会变得
of a higher quality. So those are just the four quadrants. Now, beyond those four quadrants sit the 26 competency areas. So within the 26 competency areas, there's all sorts like personal power is a really big one for me. power was the the one competency area that was actually pulling my overall eq score down i have a very high eq score only because i've been working on it not because i'm some kind of a you know superhero or something like that i used to have a poor eq uh sort of profile but i've worked on it over the years. But this one competency is still dragging it down. And personal power is really about your relationship with you. What kind of conversations are you having with you? So we talk about imposter
更高。所以这只是四个象限。现在，在这四个象限之外，还有 26 个能力领域。在 26 个能力领域中，有各种各样的东西，比如“个人力量”（Personal Power）对我来说就是一个非常大的领域。个人力量是唯一一个实际上拉低我整体情商得分的能力领域。我的情商得分很高，只是因为我一直在努力，而不是因为我是什么超级英雄之类的。我过去的情商状况很差，但我多年来一直在努力改善。但这个能力仍然在拖后腿。个人力量实际上是关于你与自己的关系。你正在与自己进行什么样的对话？我们谈论“冒名顶替
syndrome. We talk about self-esteem. All of that fits within this concept of personal power. So we need to find out how do we improve? How can we improve our self-esteem? How can we have better quality conversations with ourselves? How can we build a better relationship with ourselves that is as good as the relationships that we have with other people? Sometimes we are our worst enemy and we can be the biggest bully to ourselves. And yet we wouldn't look to wouldn't tolerate bullying in anybody else.
综合征”。我们谈论自尊。所有这些都符合“个人力量”这个概念。所以我们需要找出我们如何改进？我们如何提高自尊？我们如何与自己进行更高质量的对话？我们如何建立一种与自己更好的关系，就像我们与他人建立的关系一样好？有时我们是我们自己最大的敌人，我们可以成为对自己最大的霸凌者。然而，我们却不会容忍别人霸凌。
So for me, this is about changing language and constantly being aware of the language that we're using with ourselves on a day to day basis and learning how to reframe that language, challenge that language. And sometimes if the language cannot be changed, then it's about watching your actions because that language will lead to actions or inaction. So watching your actions, really policing your mind, using the analogy from my past, policing your mind and policing your actions. So if your thinking is not of good quality, you adjust that. If you're not able to adjust that then it's
所以对我来说，这是关于改变语言，并时刻意识到我们每天对自己使用的语言，并学习如何重构这种语言，挑战这种语言。有时如果语言无法改变，那么就是观察你的行动，因为语言会导致行动或不作为。所以观察你的行动，真正地“监管”你的思想——用我过去的比喻——监管你的思想和监管你的行动。如果你的思维质量不高，你就调整它。如果你无法调整它，那么就是
actually looking at the action so you might find yourself doing something or not doing something as a case maybe and saying actually that's not good for me so i need to get off my backside and i need to go and you know we were talking about linkedin a while ago marianne and we're talking about improving our profiles on linkedin i thought to myself, I really don't want to do this, but I need to do it. So let's get it done. So that's my attitude in life now. To overcome my personal power issues, I just tell myself the job needs doing, get it done. So I've coined a phrase, which you might see up here, do it now, it says. Hashtag do it now. Yeah. And for me, the moment I think about doing something,
真正地审视行动。所以你可能会发现自己在做某事或不做某事，并说：“实际上，这对我不利，所以我需要从屁股上起来，我需要去……”你知道，Marianne，我们刚才在谈论 LinkedIn，在谈论改善我们在 LinkedIn 上的个人资料。我心想：“我真的不想做这个，但我必须做。”所以让我们把它完成。这就是我现在的生活态度。为了克服我的个人力量问题，我只是告诉自己：工作需要完成，把它完成。所以我创造了一个短语，你可能在这里看到，写着“现在就做”（Do it now）。标签：#现在就做。是的。对我来说，当我想到要做某事时，
whether it's grasping an opportunity or doing something that I really don't want to do, Brian Tracy will call it eating your frog, doing a task that's unpleasant, I just get it done and I get it done in the here and now. Do it now. And that philosophy has served me well I used to be the worst procrastinator in the world but now I at least I get things done you know absolutely it's really powerful stuff and you know reflecting on what you've said you know
无论是抓住机会还是做一些我真的不想做的事情——Brian Tracy 会称之为“吃掉那只青蛙”，做一项令人不快的任务——我只是把它完成，而且是在此时此地完成。现在就做。这种哲学对我很有帮助。我曾经是世界上最严重的拖延症患者，但现在至少我能把事情做完。你知道，这绝对是非常强大的东西。回顾你所说的，
I trained in the doctoral program between 2008 and 2011 and it was very much about upskilling us to have the necessary skills to be a good enough clinician with our clients our mental health clients when we're in the room but there wasn't really much of an emphasis on compassion and self-talk and the quality of your thoughts and I really have spent time since I've been supporting aspiring psychologists really trying to warm up the compassion warm up the temperature of the water and encourage people to look after themselves because often there won't be anyone coming to rescue you and I think I really hope that the doctoral programs are going to start embracing and doing some more of that as
我在 2008 年到 2011 年间接受了博士项目培训，它主要是关于提升我们的技能，使我们成为一名足够好的临床医生，在房间里与我们的心理健康客户相处。但并没有太多关于同情心、自我对话和思想质量的强调。自从我开始支持有抱负的心理学家以来，我真的花了很多时间试图温暖同情心，提高水的温度，并鼓励人们照顾好自己，因为通常不会有人来拯救你。我真的希望博士项目能开始拥抱并做更多这样的事情，
well so there was personal development there was a personal tutor relationship but in terms of the stuff I needed to get me through life you know in terms of becoming a parent and losing a dad and you know managing a busy um you know caseload and teams and stepping into leadership roles when I hadn't really been taught how to do that compassion is needed you know like you said you've had imposter syndrome and even me as a qualified psychologist i've been qualified uh 10 years over 10 years um you still have imposter syndrome you know of course absolutely and that's okay but that's really normal it's just part of having these really tricky human brains of ours and so i really hope that with you know your support and the support of other people that have got compassionate voices in the field that we can not just equip fully qualified clinical psychologists
也是如此。所以有个人发展，有个人导师关系，但就我度过人生所需的那些东西而言，你知道，比如成为父母、失去父亲、管理繁忙的病例和团队，以及在没有被教导如何做的情况下担任领导角色，同情心是必要的。你知道，就像你说的，你有过冒名顶替综合征，即使是我作为一名合格的心理学家，我已经合格了 10 年多，超过 10 年了，你仍然会有冒名顶替综合征。你知道，当然，绝对是这样。但这没关系，这真的很正常。这只是我们这些棘手的人类大脑的一部分。所以我真的希望，有你的支持，以及其他在这一领域拥有富有同情心的声音的人的支持，我们不仅能装备完全合格的临床心理学家，
but to equip people with life skills that help them to be able to navigate their own lives which then help people to navigate their clients lives as well absolutely you know this whole issue of imposter syndrome we talk about it as if we're the only people that suffer from it i would suggest that 90 of the people that you meet on a day-to-day basis will have some level of imposter syndrome i recall when i was a senior police officer and a highly highly specialized specialized critical incident gold commander. I was like at the top end, the very top end of any major incident. I was, I'd been on so many courses.
还能装备人们具备帮助他们驾驭自己生活的技能，这反过来也能帮助人们驾驭客户的生活。绝对的。你知道，整个“冒名顶替综合征”的问题，我们谈论它时，好像我们是唯一受此困扰的人。我想说，你每天遇到的人中，90% 都会有某种程度的冒名顶替综合征。我记得当我是一名高级警官和高度专业化的突发事件黄金指挥官时。我处于顶端，任何重大事件的最顶端。我参加过很多课程。
I was highly experienced. And, you know, thankfully, I never made a mistake in that sense where somebody's life was at risk. But do you know what? Every single time with every single incident, there was a touch of imposter syndrome. So in whichever field you're in, I would suspect that at some point in time,
我经验丰富。而且，你知道，谢天谢地，我从未犯过那种有人生命处于危险之中的错误。但你知道吗？每一次，每一个事件，都有那么一点点冒名顶替综合征。所以无论你在哪个领域，我怀疑在某个时间点，
if we are not guarding the gates of our mind, the imposter syndrome will creep through. So we need to be prepared all the time. We need to be alert all the time. We need to be alert all the time for this negative language, these limiting beliefs creeping in, and we need to have some kind of a strategy to deal with them. And when it comes to emotional intelligence and EQ, I think we have been conditioned to believe that technical skills, qualifications and IQ are everything that you need in life to be successful in life. But that's not true, as you've just quite rightly identified there.
如果我们不守住思想的大门，冒名顶替综合征就会潜入。所以我们需要时刻准备着。我们需要时刻保持警惕。我们需要时刻警惕这种负面语言、这些限制性信念的潜入，我们需要某种策略来应对它们。当谈到情商和 EQ 时，我认为我们被灌输了一种观念，认为技术技能、资格和智商（IQ）是你一生中成功所需的一切。但那不是真的，正如你刚才非常正确地指出的那样。
IQ, technical skills and qualification will get you to a certain point. But if beyond that point you want to be successful then it has to be about EQ it has to be about how good is the conversation that you're having with you how good are the conversations that you're having with other people how good are you at understanding the social context in the environment in which you live work or operate and how well can you manage your behaviour or manage or perceive the emotions in other people? How well can you read a situation? How well can you read people? How well can you communicate? What kind of language do you use? What's your tonality like? What's your connectability like? All of these kind of things are absolutely critically important and you've touched upon
智商、技术技能和资格会让你达到某一点。但如果在那之后你想获得成功，那么它必须是关于情商（EQ）。它必须是关于你与自己进行的对话有多好，你与他人进行的对话有多好，你对生活、工作或运作环境中的社会背景的理解有多好，以及你管理自己的行为、管理或感知他人情绪的能力有多好？你解读情况的能力如何？你解读人的能力如何？你沟通的能力如何？你使用什么样的语言？你的语调如何？你的连接能力如何？所有这些事情都绝对至关重要。你触及了
something very important marion i absolutely believe that when you have high levels of emotional intelligence from that you'll also build high levels of emotional resilience so when you do come under these very testing and challenging times that let's face it we all will or do at some point i literally have lost count of how many dead bodies i've seen or how many post-mortems i've been to that emotional resilience comes doesn't just come automatically it can be built over time when you learn how to a identify your thoughts and your emotions and how they impact on your thinking and then learn how to make friends with yourself so that you your emotions don't serve as a as the chimpanzee as steve peters often talks about in
一些非常重要的事情，Marianne。我绝对相信，当你拥有高水平的情商时，你也会建立高水平的情绪韧性。所以当你确实处于这些非常考验和挑战的时刻时——让我们面对现实吧，我们所有人都会或多或少在某个时候经历——我真的数不清我见过多少具尸体，或者我参加过多少次尸检。那种情绪韧性不是自动产生的，它是可以通过时间建立的，当你学会：A，识别你的想法和情绪，以及它们如何影响你的思维；然后学会与自己交朋友，这样你的情绪就不会成为史蒂夫·彼得斯（Steve Peters）经常谈论的
this chimp paradox it's not some wild creature inside your brain running wild so you become irrational you have to allow your prefrontal cortex to kick in so you can make these rational logical empathic decisions in life yeah yeah absolutely absolutely it's really golden stuff carl um have you got like top tips for if people want to like make a change that's going to make a big change for them? What would be, like, your take-home piece of advice? Well, I would suggest something around self-awareness is critical. In this very, very fast world in which we exist, it's very hard nowadays to actually sit down, put the phones away, all of these distracting things away, and actually sit
“黑猩猩悖论”（Chimp Paradox）中的那只黑猩猩。它不是你大脑中乱跑的野兽，所以你变得非理性。你必须允许你的前额叶皮层介入，这样你才能在生活中做出这些理性的、逻辑的、富有同情心的决定。是的，是的，绝对是。这真是金玉良言，Carl。嗯，你有没有什么顶级建议，如果人们想做出一个能为他们带来巨大改变的改变？你的“带回家”建议是什么？嗯，我会建议围绕自我意识的一些东西是至关重要的。在我们所处的这个非常非常快节奏的世界里，现在很难真正坐下来，把手机收起来，把所有这些分散注意力的东西收起来，真正坐
down with a pen and paper. And in doing that, really analyse where you've been, and where you intend to go, and where you are right now. And within that, it's almost like doing a SWOT analysis on yourself. What are your strengths in everything that you've ever done and everything that you could ever do? What are the weaknesses in everything that you've ever experienced and what you could do in the future? What could be your future weaknesses? But in doing the weaknesses, I would suggest that you look
下来，拿一支笔和一张纸。在这样做的时候，真正分析你曾经去过哪里，你打算去哪里，以及你现在在哪里。在其中，这几乎就像是对自己进行 SWOT 分析。你在你做过的所有事情和你可能做的所有事情中，你的优势是什么？在你经历过的所有事情和你未来能做的事情中，你的弱点是什么？你未来的弱点可能是什么？但在分析弱点时，我建议你看看……
for evidence-based thinking. We can make up all the weaknesses in the world, but what's the evidence to substantiate that this is actually a credible weakness? So I have to put this caveat. You're doing a bit of CBT there, Carl, whether you know it or not. Thank you. And then, of course, the opportunities. So what is it around you in life?
为了基于证据的思考。我们可以编造出世界上所有的弱点，但有什么证据能证实这确实是一个可信的弱点呢？所以我必须加上这个警告。卡尔，你刚才在做一点认知行为疗法（CBT），不管你是否意识到。谢谢。当然，还有机会。那么你生活中周围有什么呢？
What relationships exist or potential relationships? What access do you have to in groups environments that you could now nurture and grow and evolve what relationships and finally the threats so i don't like the threats part you know when we talk about the swot analysis i very rarely pay much attention to threat i'll tell you before we're conditioned from the moment that we are born to live in a very competitive environment. So even in business, people talk about competitors. I literally have no competitors. That's my vision in life. I have no competitors in life, no competitors in business. I had no competitors in the police service. I can only
存在哪些关系或潜在关系？你有什么渠道进入那些可以培养、成长和发展关系的群体环境？最后是威胁。我不喜欢威胁这部分，你知道，当我们谈论SWOT分析时，我很少关注威胁。我告诉你，我们从出生那一刻起就被训练生活在一个竞争非常激烈的环境中。所以即使在商业中，人们也会谈论竞争对手。我真的没有竞争对手。这就是我的人生愿景。我在生活中没有竞争对手，在商业中也没有竞争对手。我在警队时也没有竞争对手。我只能
compete with me. So if there is a threat, it's the quality of the person that you are in the police service. I can only compete with me. So if there is a threat, it's the quality of the person that you are in the here and now, how you're showing up. Don't worry about the potential competitors around you. There's a really good book, Marion, I don't know if you know, from Simon Sinek, who is one of my heroes in leadership. Simon Sinek talks about the infinite mind. I think it's called The Infinite Game Simon Sinek talks about the infinite mind. I think it's called the infinite game, but he talks about the infinite mind. He says in life, there are two mindsets. There's the infinite mindset and there's a finite mindset. The finite mindset is the leader who has a winning post. They say, right, by the time I'm 30, I want to achieve this, or my goal
与自己竞争。所以如果存在威胁，那就是你在警队中作为个人的素质。我只能与自己竞争。所以如果存在威胁，那就是你此时此刻作为个人的素质，你表现出的状态。不要担心你周围潜在的竞争对手。有一本非常好的书，玛丽安，不知道你知不知道，是西蒙·斯涅克写的，他是我的领导力偶像之一。西蒙·斯涅克谈到了无限思维。我想它叫《无限博弈》，但他谈到了无限思维。他说在生活中，有两种思维模式。一种是无限思维，一种是有限思维。有限思维是那些有终点的领导者。他们说，好吧，到30岁时，我想实现这个，或者我的目标
now is to get to here but then you have to ask yourself well when you get to that winning post when you get to that goal what then and that for me is a finite mindset it's a very limiting mindset whereas the infinite mindset says I want to go in this direction and I want to keep going and keep learning and keep being curious I want to keep growing throughout my entire in the entirety entirety of my journey. And what you'll find is if they were to go for the same amount of period, the one with a growth mindset, the infinite mindset will have grown 10 times than the person with a finite mindset. So do a SWOT analysis on yourself, use a caveat that I've put in place there, come at it with an infinite mindset and see where where you are that's all about self-awareness
现在是达到这里，但你必须问自己，当你到达那个终点，当你实现那个目标时，然后呢？对我来说，这是一种有限的思维，这是一种非常局限的思维。而无限思维则说，我想朝着这个方向前进，我想继续前进，继续学习，保持好奇心。我想在整个旅程中不断成长。你会发现，如果他们走同样长的时间，拥有成长型思维、无限思维的人会比拥有有限思维的人成长十倍。所以对自己做一次SWOT分析，使用我刚才提到的那个警告，带着无限思维去分析，看看你处于什么位置，这完全是关于自我意识的。
really getting an understanding of where you are who you are in the here and now and then you can start moving forward great i wonder if the same might be useful for helping people step into their leadership as well because as um you know psychologists we graduate um as band seven in the nhs which is quite high up bearing in mind it now starts at band two. And generally the top of the pay scales would be band nine, but they do go on beyond that for more senior levels, but they're not banded. There's an expectation that you're going to have some sort of leadership role, ultimately. Certainly as you go up to band eight a and b and c you know and d but that's sort of it can be a tricky thing to get your head around the fact
真正了解你此时此刻处于什么位置、你是谁，然后你就可以开始前进了。太棒了，我想知道同样的方法是否也有助于帮助人们迈向领导力，因为作为心理学家，我们在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）毕业时是七级（Band 7），这已经相当高了，考虑到现在是从二级开始的。通常薪资等级的最高点是九级，但他们确实会超过这个级别进入更高级别，但它们没有分级。最终人们期望你担任某种领导角色。当然，当你升到八级A、B、C和D时，但要理解这一点可能是一件棘手的事情
that maybe as soon as you qualify you go from trainee to qualified then they're looking for leadership and it's it's not necessarily something that's that easy to get experience of on the way up so how do we get our heads around that and get any good at it, Cole? That's a really good question. I've done a lot of work with the NHS, both in terms of culture change and leadership development. And I understand how the bandings work. But there are a lot of positions where you are in a similar position to that which you've just described. So for example, doctors, doctors don't train to be leaders, they train to be doctors, dentists, I'm just doing some
也许你一获得资格，就从实习生变成了合格人员，然后他们就开始寻找领导力，而在晋升过程中获得这种经验并不容易。所以我们该如何理解这一点并擅长它呢，科尔？这是一个非常好的问题。我在NHS做了很多工作，包括文化变革和领导力发展。我了解分级是如何运作的。但有很多职位和你刚才描述的情况类似。例如，医生，医生不是为了成为领导者而受训，他们是为了成为医生而受训，牙医，我刚好在做一些
work with some dentists, they don't train to become a leader, they train to become a dentist. But the addition to that is that they automatically are seen as leaders as soon as they start working. Right. And it's no different with psychologists. So for me, leadership is not about the position that you own in an organization. Leadership is about how you show up in life. Let me explain that in a bit more with a bit more sort of common sense, really. I once trawled Google for the definition of leadership. And firstly, I was astounded that on the word leadership, I came up with nearly four billion responses in 0.67 seconds, which demonstrates that there's a lot of people interested in leadership.
与牙医相关的工作，他们不是为了成为领导者而受训，他们是为了成为牙医而受训。但除此之外，他们一旦开始工作，就会自动被视为领导者。心理学家也是如此。所以对我来说，领导力与你在组织中拥有的职位无关。领导力是关于你在生活中如何表现。让我用更常识性的方式解释一下。我曾经在谷歌上搜索过领导力的定义。首先，我感到震惊的是，关于“领导力”这个词，我在0.67秒内得到了近40亿条结果，这表明很多人对领导力感兴趣。
Well, if it's nearly four billion, that's nearly half the world right but then when i look for the definition of leadership the definition i got was uh leader leadership is when you are leading an organization or you're leading a group of people now i don't know about you but if you have to use a word leadership sorry leading to describe the word, it's almost like the dictionary itself doesn't understand leadership. So being a non-conformist, I came up with my own definition, which I think is far more accurate. I think you are a leader whenever you are influencing people, you're influencing circumstances. Now within that, that should help to identify the answers to your question, because we can, therefore, be a leader way before we become a doctor in psychology, if we are influencing our pets because they look up to us for guidance as the alpha male, alpha female, if we are influencing friends because they see us as being an expert in a certain area, so therefore they come to us for advice,
好吧，如果接近40亿，那几乎是世界人口的一半了。但当我寻找领导力的定义时，我得到的定义是：领导力就是当你领导一个组织或领导一群人时。现在我不知道你怎么想，但如果你必须用“领导”这个词来描述“领导力”，这就像字典本身也不理解领导力。作为一个不墨守成规的人，我想出了我自己的定义，我认为这更准确。我认为只要你在影响他人、影响环境，你就是一个领导者。在这一点内，这应该有助于找到你问题的答案，因为我们可以在成为心理学博士之前很久就成为领导者，如果我们正在影响我们的宠物，因为它们把我们视为向导，视为阿尔法雄性或雌性；如果我们正在影响朋友，因为他们认为我们在某个领域是专家，所以他们来找我们寻求建议，
or they just see us as an agony aunt and agony uncle, all of these are leadership roles. If you're the elder sibling, it's a leadership role. If your parents are getting old and they're now leaning on you, that's a leadership role. So if these are all leadership roles and these are just roles in life, let alone going in, working in NHS or anywhere else, it's as well that we start getting our leadership skills right from the outset. It's about reading the books. It's about practicing emotional intelligence. It's about becoming much, much more self-aware, analyzing ourselves. It's about asking for feedback, but then creating the environment
或者他们只是把我们当作倾诉对象，所有这些都是领导角色。如果你是长兄长姐，这也是一个领导角色。如果你的父母正在变老，现在开始依赖你，那也是一个领导角色。所以如果这些都是领导角色，而这些仅仅是生活中的角色，更不用说进入NHS或其他任何地方工作了，我们最好从一开始就掌握好我们的领导技能。这关乎阅读书籍，关乎练习情商，关乎变得更加自我意识，分析我们自己。这关乎寻求反馈，但也要创造环境
for that person to feel safe to give you feedback. You know, people often talk about asking for feedback, but it's no good unless you create a safe environment so there's psychological safety for the individual giving the feedback back to you if you do all of that then actually you're you're already on the journey to be becoming a leader and the natural transition from you being at a band seven to going further thereafter is so subtle it will almost be unnoticeable so leadership is something that we can all learn it's not something that we're born with it's something that we learn throughout our the entirety of our lives but we have to look for
让那个人感到安全并给你反馈。你知道，人们经常谈论寻求反馈，但除非你创造一个安全的环境，否则是没有用的，这样给反馈的人才会感到心理安全。如果你做到了所有这些，那么实际上你已经在成为领导者的旅程上了，从七级到进一步发展的自然过渡是如此微妙，几乎难以察觉。所以领导力是我们所有人都能学习的东西，它不是我们与生俱来的，而是我们在整个生命中学习的东西，但我们必须在
leadership in the most in the most sort of unexpected areas of our lives don't align it to our work or position align it to who we are so the boots on the ground example for our audience would be i guess cultural temperature of organizations and how people want to show up in terms of dignity and respect for their clients, taking time for their colleagues, not being afraid to use their voice so long as they're using it in a compassionate way. They've got a plan where they're going, and they can guide people gently by the elbow to get there in a way that feels supportive.
生活中最意想不到的领域寻找领导力。不要把它与我们的工作或职位挂钩，要把它与我们是谁挂钩。对于我们的听众来说，脚踏实地的例子可能是组织的文化温度，以及人们如何以尊严和尊重对待客户、花时间陪伴同事、不害怕表达自己的声音，只要他们以富有同情心的方式表达。他们有一个前进的计划，并且可以温柔地引导人们到达那里，以一种让人感到支持的方式。
Absolutely. And if you think about the role that a psychologist performs, you have got such an important role in somebody's life. You are influencing their life. That's a leadership role. And I loved what you're talking about, the cultural temperature. If you are going to work within the NHS, remember that all of these NHS trusts up and down the country, they will all have similar but different cultures. There will be subcultures that exist within an umbrella culture. So work for an organisation whose culture aligns with your culture,
绝对是这样。如果你想想心理学家所扮演的角色，你在某人的生活中扮演着如此重要的角色。你正在影响他们的生活。这是一个领导角色。我很喜欢你谈到的文化温度。如果你要在NHS工作，请记住，全国各地的所有NHS信托机构，它们都有相似但不同的文化。在伞形文化下会存在亚文化。所以，为那些文化与你的文化相一致的组织工作，
whose values align with your values, and then you'll feel happier in that workplace. I've just done a cultural diagnostic on a healthcare provider with 1,400 staff, and there are so many staff who are frustrated, angry, upset, scared about being in that organisation because the culture is not right. So it really is about the values and the culture need to be one, they need to be synonymous. But also the values of the organisation and the individuals in the organisation need to be aligned. So test yourself at that level. Next time you go for a job application,
价值观与你的价值观相一致，那么你在那个工作场所会感到更快乐。我刚刚对一家拥有1400名员工的医疗保健提供商进行了文化诊断，有太多的员工因为文化不正确而对身处该组织感到沮丧、愤怒、不安和恐惧。所以这确实是关于价值观和文化需要合二为一，它们需要是同义词。而且组织的价值观和组织中的个人的价值观也需要保持一致。所以在那个层面上测试自己。下次你去申请工作时，
don't just look at the banding or the wage or the money that comes from it or the position that you get. Ask yourself, would I be happy working in this organisation? That is such an important point and a wonderful one to leave it on. Carl, how can people find out more about you, about your book, about your upcoming book as well? Where is the best place for people to connect with you? Okay, so the best place, I guess, is either through my website, which is www.igniteyourinnerpotential.com or just find me on LinkedIn. I'm always looking for people to connect with me on LinkedIn. So it's Cole Mahay on LinkedIn. That's K-U-L. And second name is Mahay, M-A-H-A-Y.
不要只看分级、工资、金钱或你得到的职位。问问自己，在这个组织工作我会快乐吗？这是一个非常重要的观点，也是一个很好的结束语。卡尔，人们如何了解更多关于你、你的书以及你即将出版的书？人们与你联系的最佳方式是什么？好的，我想最好的方式要么是通过我的网站，即www.igniteyourinnerpotential.com，要么就在LinkedIn上找到我。我一直在寻找在LinkedIn上与我联系的人。所以是Cole Mahay，在LinkedIn上。拼写是K-U-L，姓氏是Mahay，M-A-H-A-Y。
Find me on LinkedIn. Connect with me. I'm always happy to connect. Perfect. Thank you so much for your time. It's been a pleasure. You're so welcome. I've enjoyed it. Thank you. Oh, thank you for your time in watching and listening. Isn't Carl just, you know, super inspiring? He's like a little rocket in your pocket that you can keep there for a day where you need a little bit of motivating self-talk, which I know that many of you have been in contact to say that this is what I do for you too. You know, I help you weather the storm of this wild ride in clinical psychology or the route to other qualified psychology routes too.
在LinkedIn上找到我。与我联系。我总是很高兴能建立联系。太完美了。非常感谢你的时间。这真是一次愉快的交流。不客气。我很享受。谢谢。哦，谢谢你们观看和收听。卡尔是不是超级鼓舞人心？他就像你口袋里的一枚小火箭，你可以在需要一点激励性的自我对话时把它拿出来，我知道你们很多人都联系过我说，这也是我为你们所做的。你知道，我帮助你们度过临床心理学这条狂野之路的风暴，或者通往其他合格心理学途径的道路。
Thank you so much for listening. And I will catch you for the next episode of The Aspiring Psychologist, which will drop in to your favorite podcast supplier at 6 a.m. on Monday. Take care. Be kind to you. And thank you for being in my world. Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there
非常感谢你们的收听。我会在下一期《有抱负的心理学家》中与你们见面，该节目将于周一早上6点发布在你最喜欢的播客供应商处。保重。善待自己。感谢你们出现在我的世界里。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将在成为合格心理学家的路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。达到目标有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到惊讶，
and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且成为一名临床心理学家没有完美的方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。